First, I was afraid.
I was petrified.
Kept thinking I could never live without you by my side.
But then I spent so many nights...
...thinking how you did me wrong.
And I grew strong.
And I learned how to get along.
And so you're back...
You have to march.
...from outer space.
I just walked in to find you here with that sad look upon your face.
I should have changed that stupid lock.
I should have made you leave your key.
If I'd known for just one second...
...you'd be back to bother me.
Go on now, go.
Walk out the door.
Just turn around now...
...'cause you're not welcome anymore.
Weren't you the one who tried to hurt me with goodbye?
Did you think I'd crumble?
You think I'd lay down and die?
Oh no, not I,...
...I will survive.
Oh, as long as I know how to love I know I'll stay alive.
I've got all my life to live.
And I've got all my love to give.
And I'll survive.
I will survive.
Hey, hey!
I like that part.
I will survive!